l'album s'appelle maintenant on dit
pareil en anglais on dit pareil on peut
employer le mot on veut dire aussi bête
ça veut dire qu'on aime pas ça fait
longtemps qu'on s'entend veut traduire
quelque chose d'assez triste et son
sinistre que ce sont dans ce cas là je
voulais traduire la tristesse qui à
l'intérieur de la chanson de détestation
de soi même mais ça peut être
intéressant quand tu fais un album comme
ça extrême
je fais pas mal d'autres avant tu dois
chercher fouiller creuser un petit peu
des fois il faut descendre dans les
profondeurs qui travaillent dans
beaucoup de studios pour cet album à los
angeles à new york à paris à nassau
pourquoi tu me bouge tout le temps tu
peux travailler seulement quand tu es en
studio je suis pas très bon dans la
préparation
je vais pas directement aux choses
[Musique]
je crains une façon un peu seul en tout
temps mais entre ça peut donner des
choses intéressent du change des choses
sur les paroles tu cherches des choses
plus intéressantes
puis des fois tu as plus de temps le
studio puis tu es obligé de te casser
alors tu vas ailleurs mais ça t'apporte
une autre inspiration
oui des fois parce qu'un ingénieur du
son qui parquet pas la queue dans un
studio
il ya des musiciens voulaient avoir des
musiciens un peu star c'est difficile de
les réunir tous oui en général je fais
une chose dans chaque endroit mais cette
fois ci j'ai fait ça à l'ancienne façon
c'est à dire que j'ai réuni tout le
monde au même endroit pour bête noire
j'utilise de la couleur de la musique
argentine
est-ce que c'est très mélodramatique
c'est très émotionnel
c'est fantastique je les ai vus à new
york il ya quelques années will tango
argentino
j'ai vu un lien j'ouvrais le new york
times et pise cherchait un endroit un
soir j'ai vu cette petite annonce
l'arrivée de paris je suis allé les voir
c'était génial
c'est vrai quand tu es en studio en
train de bosser sur un album tu arrives
pas à décider quand c'est fini
il faut vraiment eu deux tirs et les des
bandes comme certains pains de saleh de
retirer les étoiles normalement la
chanson doit dire d'elle même quand elle
est finie mais il faut vraiment te tirer
les les bancs presque oui c'est pourquoi
les corps d'armée
il ya beaucoup de peintres à qui c'est
arrivé ça marche on était obligé
vraiment l'ordre de l'étoile
tu te sens plus comme un peintre comme
un écrivain et c'est pour ça que tu sors
seulement un album tous les deux ou
trois ans oui dans ce contexte là c'est
pas tellement étonnant j'ai des amis
peintres qui font des expos tous les ai
tous les deux ou trois ans c'est dur
finalement de faire un essai londres
c'est quelque chose que tu penses est
bien je pense que dans ce milieu
finalement les gens qui font des choses
un petit peu trop vite quand tu es à
paris qu'est ce que tu fais tu vas voir
les musées ouais souvent mais quel genre
de musée il ya quelques semaines je suis
allé à versailles
cette fois ci j'ai vu déjà quand j'étais
étudiant j'avais vu l'intérieur
j'ai un ami de de londres qui est
complètement obsédé trop louis xiv qui
m'a montré les jardins fait c'est
tellement bien
c'est fascinant ça t'inspire
c'est vrai que c'est dur d'imaginer un
truc aussi dingue que j'aime beaucoup le
musée picasso déjà à l'hôtel particulier
c'est tellement plus
c'est une façon de c1 avait fini a créé
ce qui est intéressant c'est voir
comment d'année en année il se recréer
complètement comment il change de style
ce service est simple
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
didio cib becm mec tu as vu l'expo bacon
j'ai le long on l'a vu dans l'émission
c'est la seule émission de télé qu'il a
fait j'ai rencontré ya quelques années
voulait faire un portrait de moi
j'aurais adoré ça m'ennuie jamais arrivé
à se trouver parce que quand il était à
paris j'étais à landreau mais qu'est ce
tu fais d'autres tels les filles si je
passe du temps avec ma femme
[Musique]
t'as pas vraiment changé depuis dix ans
j'ai quand même des petites rides mais
tu as une vie tranquille
ce que j'aime chez les contrastes soi
quand on fait un 10 bon on est en studio
ont su
sort c'est pour ça que j'aime bien être
accompagné en angleterre ça c'est
tranquille je crois que c'est important
de garder du temps pour soi même
l'espèce de jardin secret et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de l'humanitude
abonnez vous mais c'est un peu ce bleu